now we all think that um alzheimer's is
a brain problem that starts in the brain
right it starts in the brain and then it
develops in the brain and it's not
connected to any other part
but i found some real interesting data
that shows that
alzheimer's actually originates in your
liver
the liver has a function of clearing out
something called
amyloid b plaques and so the liver
should normally clear this out so it
doesn't spread into
other parts of your body but when the
liver is compromised
and it can't do that whether you have a
fatty liver
you have cirrhosis you have inflammation
you have diabetes you have metabolic
syndrome
whatever then the liver is going to have
a very very hard time
getting rid of that plaquing and then it
starts developing in the brain
but you you won't have symptoms for
roughly about 20 years
then you start getting the dementia so
it's a
process and the problem is that a lot of
times people are waiting until they get
a symptom before they do anything
about it but i want to emphasize this
very very important connection that you
need to know about
especially if you want to prevent
alzheimer's so what can you do well
number one take care of your liver
right i have a lot of videos on this
i'll put some links down below
very very important but let's say for
example you're already starting to get
dementia you start going in a room you
can't quite remember why you went in
there and you start
losing your keys and you just start
having memory loss you're getting a
little bit older and you're concerned
what you need to do is start to
support your liver immediately well
there's a couple things you can do
there's actually
four really important things to do and
so these few articles down below cover
these points
and i think it's actually quite
fascinating bile salts
specifically a type of biosolid called
tudka
has the ability to decrease amyloid
plaquing and amyloid clearing
in the hippocampus which is the part of
the brain that
is involved with the relay to your
database or remembering certain things
especially spatial memory and by the way
if you go on a low
fat diet your bio salts dry up
also if you destroy your gut
you're not going to be able to make bile
salts because your body makes secondary
bile salts
from the microbes in your gut that's one
of the reasons why there's a big
connection between your gut
and your brain what's going on down here
is affecting up
here number two vitamin d and by the way
if you don't have bile salts or not
enough bile salts
you're not going to be able to absorb
vitamin d so there's a big
connection between vitamin d and
clearing out
amyloid plaquing also vitamin d is very
very important in the liver
and the liver is part of the
process where the vitamin d gets
activated
it's also an organ that you help store
vitamin d
but vitamin d is very very important all
right number three silly marin that's
milk thistle has the capacity to clear
out amyloid
plaquing so if you're getting dementia
or you have alzheimer's
you should be taking all these including
the next point which is intermittent
fasting
intermittent fasting helps clear out the
amyloid plaquing
why because your body starts to
perform autophagy which is a recycling
of proteins that you don't need
and you'd have to do at least 18 hours
of fasting to get into autophagy but
very very important if you want to clear
out these proteins
all right thanks for watching hey before
you go real quick
i have a course entitled how to
bulletproof
your immune system it's a free course i
want you to take it
and here's why here's you
here is your environment
everyone is focused on this over here
avoiding
your environment but what about here
what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself and so you can
tolerate and resist
your environment much better by
strengthening
your own immune system i put a link down
in the description right down below
check it out and get signed up today